well as promised we can get more now on
the war in Ukraine in February 2022
Moscow had planned to take control of
Ukraine in a matter of days but the
Ukrainian resistance has slowed Russia's
progress and days as we know turned into
months where we can get analysis now on
how the first weeks of the war unfolded
from Professor Michael Clarke
thanks Sam this is the actual
anniversary of the beginning of the war
The Day The Invasion took place so this
is the 366th day of what was intended to
be a three-day War
and we know that it was intended to be a
three-day War now we're sure because the
Russians intended to grab Kiev in the
first three days and within a couple of
weeks to have pacified and settled the
other cities that they intended to take
and so it was a four front War to begin
with a push towards Kiev from Belarus
and from the Northwestern districts of
the Russian border a push towards the
cities in the uh the Northeast pushing
the donbass and the easiest push of all
uh northward from Crimea where the
logistics were easier the distances
weren't so great to actually move up to
grab this land bridge between the
donbass and Kirsten and then push
towards Odessa and take the port the
third city of Ukraine itself and in
those early days we our attention of
course was all on care what was
happening there two things were really
important Hospital airport the Airfield
the vdv the Russian uh airborne troops
took hospital and that was important
they wanted to use that as a jumping off
place to grab the government in Kiev and
then they could use that to bring in
thousands of troops to take the rest of
the city they took it but they lost it
again the ukrainians got it back and
that's the important thing so the
Russians lost their foothold in hospital
airport and then the second thing we
were all watching this great Convoy that
developed uh coming out of Belarus down
to the west of Kiev we were waiting for
this Convoy to surround Kiev along with
the forces coming in uh further from the
the Northeast in fact we now know it
wasn't a convoy it was a traffic jam to
a 10 Battalion tactical groups who
couldn't make Headway over the rough
ground over the boggy ground so they
headed for the road and because their
Maps weren't very good and their
coordination was terrible they all
headed for the same road so in the end
to attend thousand troops a thousand
main battle tanks two thousand four
hundred uh armored vehicles all stuck on
the same road it was a 35 mile month
long traffic jam that's what it was
eventually it all it all uh uh released
itself it sort of unraveled itself and
the battle for cave was over and so we
ended up a month after the beginning of
the war and it had looked like this Kiev
was saved because of the incompetence of
the Russian advance but they were
digging in as it were they were making
progress in the other cities in the in
the North in the donbass and across the
land bridge the ukrainians were fighting
back in Dynamic defense they weren't
able to do very much but they were
dynamically defending wherever they
could you can't defend a single line
when you're outnumbered you just sort of
hit where you can that's what they did
effectively at this stage after a month
they were doing very well but we all
knew they were losing slowly think about
the war on the 24th of March after about
a month it was clear that the Russians
were in several areas around Kiev in the
Northeast in the donbass and in this
land bridge to the South were four big
fronts and although we could see that
the Russians were making hard work of it
we thought that they will learn they'll
get better at it they made no more hard
work of it than in the great Convoy that
was approaching Kiev from the West we
now know it wasn't a convoy it was a
Monumental traffic jam ten different
Battalion tactical groups all sought the
same road to get away from the soft
ground without proper planning proper
communication and in the end a thousand
tanks 2 400 armored vehicles ten
thousand troops were involved in a
35-mile traffic jam that spent a month
before it could unwind itself that was
Monumental but that's where the war
seemed to be after a month we thought
they'll get it right they'll move in on
these areas and try probably to move
into the area east of the Nipper River
and take the whole of this eastern part
of the country but that's where we are
today just look at the difference the
red areas indicate where the Russians
occupy the yellow areas of the two
fairly big areas that the Ukraine
region they've got right through to the
border of luhansk and in the west
they've taken back a lot of the cursing
oblasts right through to taking the city
of Kirsten itself making the Russians
abandon the city and so here are the
Russians occupying the donbass which
they now say is their prime target and
holding on to this land bridge very
important to them to maintain control of
Crimea but both slides are now preparing
their offensives as the winter plays
itself out we are expecting a lot more
maneuver on this map and we'll see in
the months to come as the winter Fades
away who has the momentum in the next
phase of this war which certainly will
run through for I guess the better part
of this year at least